what up peeps
it's me your friendly neighborhood dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message for
january 5th in the year of 2021
there's a lot going on in the world
we're gonna do some funny stuff some
silly stuff some crazy stuff some banana
stuff
and uh maybe some stuff that'll make you
rethink your whole life
in today's episode uh of course the big
thing and i'm not even going to cover it
on the show right now because it's
happening as we speak
is that there is this big election in
georgia happening
for the two senate seats two democrats
running against two republicans
it's all unfurling as we speak at the
moment i believe
unless something happens uh throughout
the day and and it certainly could with
all breaking news
i believe i will be on laura ingram on
fox tonight disc
discussing the outcome of the election
although these days with elections you
never know if you're going to get the
outcome that night
a couple days later four months later or
never so we'll see about that
and uh and then of course tomorrow is
this huge rally that trump
is doing in dc and there are literally
thousands of people now flocking to dc
from all over the country they're
calling it the stop the steel rally
trump is promising to talk he gave a big
speech in georgia yesterday where he was
implying like he's got some stuff to
drop
and we shall see but i think uh
if i can say one thing confidently at
the moment it's that the next two weeks
you know basically from
from tomorrow the sixth to the potential
inauguration day of whoever might be
inaugurated
uh it's going to be pretty crazy and i
will i will try to keep you safe
before we get to all the stories today
guys i want to talk to you
about built bar not bill barr
but built a bar are you looking for a
new protein bar that tastes like a candy
bar
i've got one i've got two
i've got three of them right here and
it's just the brand for you build bars
are super tasty and come in 18 amazing
flavors my personal favorite as you guys
know is
the cookies and cream built bars are
covered in 100 chocolate include both
nut and nut free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew
with the holidays just around the corner
although they've they've passed but
there will be holidays in a future
corner i think we're gonna have to fix
that
uh bill bars are the perfect alternative
to pie for the health conscious guy
you can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein and high fiber
go to billboard.com and use promo code
ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at builtbar.com it's good for bars
bill go or bill boost
now back to me all right so i want to
first show you
a clip from the united states
congress their opening prayer now this
clip is going viral i'm guessing a lot
of you have seen it already
i wanted to put it in yesterday's show
but we were pretty packed it's just
worth watching again because you know
when we talk about
how social justice is sort of this
really destructive force that's
rampaging through
all of our institutions and critical
race theory and the changing of words
the changing
of meaning of words the way we can't use
words
that we used to use used to use and all
of these things
it's like something very weird is
happening here but this moment
that happened at the opening prayer in
congress a few days ago by
representative emanuel cleaver he is a
democrat
this might be the most perfect example
of how
absolutely painstakingly completely
moronic and idiotic this entire movement
is
but i don't want to lead you too much so
let's look at the clip
we ask it in the name of the
monotheistic god
brahma and god known by many
names by many different faiths
a man and a woman
amen and a woman do you see how stupid
these people are they've
injected gender into things that have
nothing to do with gender
amen comes from hebrew it means so be it
the latin definition would be truth or
faithful
but putting aside the specifics of all
that the stupidity
with which these people do these things
there's also now a push
in congress of course coming from the
democrats pushed by
nancy pelosi that they're going to get
all gendered language
out of all of their resolutions although
as somebody pointed out on twitter
yesterday i think it was sean spicer
actually
and i retweeted it um in pelosi's own
twitter bio she describes herself as a
mother and a grandmother which those are
gendered terms
nancy you're eating too much ice cream
um anyway i don't need to really
go much further with this but just like
this this endless stupidity
of these people that apparently we've
elected to lead us
is just absolutely incredible amen
and a woman this is the when i talk
about how
it's the anti-racists who are the
racists and it's the people who think
that sexism
is everywhere they're the sexist it's
like that's what i mean like they're
not only are they finding it in places
where it is not but then they inject it
into everything else so so it's it's
pretty bananas but you know one of the
things i try to do
on this show is not make you bananas
right that's been one of my
my main driving points with this is is
to talk about the things that i think
are important
but not whack you over the head and not
want you know make it so that you want
to kill people after
and one way that i do that is not to
show you too much stuff
from cnn but there was this piece on cnn
yesterday
by don lemon and just for the record don
and i used to be friendly
i guess we're not anymore and he you may
remember before the election did this
whole thing on how he can't be friends
with uh with trump supporters because
they're all racists and bigots and and
the rest of it so whatever that's fine
he unfollowed me on twitter
life will go on um but this
this clip from cnn is is so incredibly
perfect
as to why cable news is making people
crazy and how it's just all performance
art and everything else and i hope
that what i do here is actually the
complete reverse of that so you're going
to see don lemon
on uh with three people each one of the
people
used to work for a republican and that's
one of the ways you can get on cnn if
you used to work for a republican
and then you'll turn your back on them
or just you know go against everything
else
that you used to talk about then you
have a great way so one of the people
and you'll see the three in a moment
but one of them worked for trump one of
them worked for ted cruz
one of them worked for marco rubio those
are the three guests
in a politically diverse panel that don
lemon
put on the cnn let's take a look
you know damn well anthony you're too
smart for that
okay well he worked for trump so i don't
know i didn't
oh my god
you work for ted cruz a full-on trader i
mean what are you talking about
you don't have any standing to say that
excuse me
excuse me anthony
and praising donald trump to the hilt
when i worked for ted cruz
you want to go there he took you he
didn't cruise
for him excuse me what was that you you
really didn't
should you didn't praise ted cruz when
you watched my work history
when you were donald trump's
communications person
willingly don't don't be don't be a
hypocrite on national team
can you imagine watching that stuff
voluntarily now in this case
you're not watching it voluntarily
because you didn't know that i was going
to throw to that right like you had
like a 20-second lead-in where i said
something was coming from cnn but there
are people who actually pick up the
remote
they're sitting there right and they're
on their couch and they've got some
snacks and they're sitting there and
they're going what's on television
to do and they stop at cnn and i'm
telling you i've said it before and i'll
say it again if you watch cnn you by the
time you change that channel you will be
dumber
and or angrier there's just no doubt
about it so anna navarro
was the the third person in the middle
uh she's the one that worked for marco
rubio so think about it you got someone
who worked for cruz someone who worked
for rubio someone who worked for trump
and they're all saying how bad the other
people are and then lemon laughs
it's just you gotta understand guys this
is not news it's it's complete
political theater and what's so
interesting and this is why i always say
this it's like so many of these
people they need the anti-trump people
the never trump people they need donald
trump
they need him to be worse than they are
right because
this one worked for rubio and now he's a
bad guy this one worked for cruz and now
he's a bad guy this one worked for trump
and he's definitely now a bad guy
so they need him because without him the
light
might be shined on them they might have
to look in the mirror and see all the
bad things that they've
done by by their own estimation by the
way although anna navarro has called me
a racist on twitter a couple
times i think she might have called me a
white supremacist it's all sort of
it all sort of blurs together at this
point anyway the point is
don't watch cnn if there's a takeaway
from today's show
don't watch cnn all right
let's do story number three uh because
this is
uh more about the crazy lockdowns and
and everything that's going on here
so anthony fauci who is the you know the
head doctor
of this whole operation who people seem
to want to appoint to be a saint or as i
call him the infallible fouchy it sounds
like a bad
80s magician look i have nothing against
the guy or for the guy right
but it's become obvious that as time has
gone on he's made
a lot of mistakes now people are not
perfect systems are not perfect i don't
necessarily think his intentions are bad
however we know that he used to tell
people not to wear masks now he wants
people to wear masks
he admitted and this came out right
before christmas i think he admitted
that he was lying
about the length of the lockdowns
because he wanted more people
to abide by them so this is a guy who
you know he he does what he's got to do
well now he's saying that we could be
back to normal
by autumn 2021 fall
2021 september october 2021 if
the country vaccinates a million people
every day okay do you realize how
bananas that is we've got a quote
from fauci in newsweek america will need
to reach a target of administering
at least one million vaccinations every
day
in order to return to some form
of normality now before i get to the
other quotes
guys again do you remember where we all
started do you remember where we started
in march when
everybody on television and everybody
that considered themselves an expert and
an analyst and a doctor and a
respectable person what did they all say
15 days to flatten the curve and we all
did it it's important that we don't
forget what
what the past was right if we're going
to be able to blaze anything that's
sensible into the future
we have to be able to remember it's one
thing we can't remember what happened
five years ago ten years ago the history
of the country that's bad enough
but can we not remember what happened
just eight months ago can we not
remember that we all did it
everyone there were virtually no people
at the beginning when we were doing that
flat in the curve thing that didn't
do all of the stuff right we were
everyone was wearing masks
everything shut down everyone was
wearing gloves
videos were viral about people that were
literally washing their grocery bags
before and washing the groceries
themselves when they would come home
we all did all of that and here we are
so we
we moved from 15 days to flatten the
curve
to now multiple states demolishing their
economies
for the same guy the same guy that's
been in charge to now say
a million people a day have to be
vaccinated
so that we can maybe get back to normal
in 2021 right like 18 months
after this thing started let's throw
this quote from abc news again this is
fouchy
if we get to 70 to 85 percent of the
population
vaccinated and we start right now we're
getting the people who are in the
priority groups
by the time we get to the end of march
the beginning of april i would have
hoped that we would have taken care of
all of those priority groups
and have what i call open season on
vaccines namely anyone who wants a
vaccine
can get a vaccine listen i don't even
want to make this about the vaccine
and i'm still a little confused why why
young
relatively young healthy people would
want to take a vaccine that was
fairly rushed out um when we know that
the virus is you know you're gonna about
a 99
uh recovery rate okay if you're if
you're relatively young and healthy so i
don't know why
people would do that again everyone
should do what precautions they think
are necessary and businesses should do
that and you should do that
in your own life and as i mentioned
yesterday i have two people that i care
about very much
in my life who have covid right now my
friend
and mentor and bonus grandfather larry
king who's 87 years old and the greatest
interviewer of all time
he has covered right now i know he's
been taking every precaution
known to man to avoid it larry's had
obviously a whole bunch of
health stuff over the years i think he's
had seven seven heart surgeries i think
he had a quintuple bypass
i mean he's been through it but i just
heard this morning actually that he's
been taken out of icu
so i'm praying for larry and his family
and then uh i have a friend who's of
college age uh who got it and he's had
some aches and and been
kind of tired but he's gonna be okay too
so i'm not diminishing the vaccine i'm
not telling you it's a conspiracy
uh the virus sorry i'm not telling you
it's a conspiracy or any of that stuff
but something the way we're constantly
moving the goal posts here
is the dangerous thing and part of what
social media does to us is
we literally forget we forget what
people said
two days ago so in an effort not to
forget what people said two days ago
let's take
a look at this video of the infallible
fouchy on 60 minutes i believe this is
in yeah this is back in march
of 2020. so this is now remember this is
about 10 months ago at the beginning of
this whole thing 15 days to flatten the
curve here's the infallible fouchy
on masks right now in the united states
people should not be walking around with
masks
you're sure of it because people are
listening really no closely to this
right now people should not be white
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people think
that it is and often there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
okay i'm not trying to be a dick here
fauci but how is that not a fireable
offense
what he is now telling us we all have to
do
back in march he was telling us it
actually might cause more problems
because you do and we all know this you
do start touching your face more right
you're wearing a mask
you start adjusting it you touch this
that the other thing we've seen all of
these ridiculous congress people they
get out there they take the mask off
they put the mask up
the mask is below
do you get it yet guys do you get it yet
i i do
hope you get it it's like why
why are we trusting people who seem to
get everything wrong if if the lockdowns
were working if all of this stuff was
working then we would be in better
situation
than we're in by the way this is totally
anecdotal but i you know i keep seeing
that
they're saying like something like uh
all not
not all of them but we're seeing like oh
90 of the hospital beds
in uh in california are overtaken socal
and l.a all the hospital beds are
overtaken there's
two hospitals that i live about 10
minutes between and i drove by both
yesterday and they're pretty much
empty i did not go in and check every
bed so i'm just telling you what i can
see on the outside which are pretty much
empty parking lots
and the lines for coveted testing that
are completely empty and everything else
it's just like what's going on here
what's going on here i don't know i'm
just
i'm just asking you the questions but
let's move on from kovid because i've
got more lunacy
coming from washington dc uh although
this is a
national story too and i'll explain why
in just a sec
a dc restaurant known as cava which is
mediterranean hummus falafel all that
good stuff
they're very very excited because
they have lessened the amount of white
employees
at cava they love diversity and they're
getting rid of whitey
and it's pretty spectacular uh here's
this image that kava put out
uh and by the way they are a national
chain there's acaba that's probably
about 15 minutes away from my house
over here and i had gone there once
although i promise you i will never go
there again
not that they'll necessarily survive
these lockdowns um
but they have this spectacular image in
bright orange very nice
telling us about the ethnic diversity of
all team members now
you know as i've said many times maybe
come back to me for a second here
as i've said many times before i get
into the kaaba specifics i'm old school
guys so when
when we hire here at the reuben report
or when i help the hiring process
at locals you know i don't look at
ethnic background i don't care about
your sexuality or your gender i just
don't care it's like can you do the job
do you seem like a decent trustworthy
honorable person then you have a pretty
good chance of getting the job i don't
care
whether you're black or white and as a
matter of fact from my
teachings as a child i thought that was
racist
but apparently i had the whole thing
backwards so now let's jump back
and uh cava it's just spectacular what
they're doing here
21 of their workforce is now white which
okay that's fine so about one five one
out of five people they're white which
is
but it's so exciting because that's down
from 2019 they lessened the white people
by 37
holy cow give them an award that's
amazing
uh they are now 14 black which is
up four percent which seems a little
racist to me it's like can you not find
a few more black people you're only up
four
i mean we knocked out whitey right we
knocked out whitey down 30
but you only up the black people four
percent that that doesn't seem right
uh hispanic they were 45
in 2019 and they're still at 45 so
i don't know if like they just they had
the perfect hispanic workforce
or they hired one hispanic they fired
one hispanic i hired a hispanic woman
lordy lordy uh and let's see
they're only three percent asian but
asians are privileged so you'd want to
depress the asian numbers you know what
i mean you wouldn't want too many asian
people having jobs
and that's up one percent so they went
they were at two percent asian and they
went to one percentage i mean this is a
company
a national company that literally posted
this
thinking they're doing something good do
you guys
get how we are right now i mean
that's the only word for it
and i'm not sorry for saying it we are
in a giant
colossal collective retardation that
that's it
uh let's see if i can pull out some
other numbers here oh i like this one
uh what was it here the uh eight percent
other
with an asterisk so eight percent
they've got 92 percent they took care of
it we got rid of white we got a certain
amount of black people and our latin
people
and the asian people but they got eight
percent other which the asterisk
says that includes american indians
and two plus races i don't know what
that means
i don't know what two plus races means
does that mean two other races and if it
does
then why didn't you name the races
because that seems pretty racist
and and why wouldn't american indian why
does american indian get thrown in with
other
like what are we talking about here
anyway i am not
person i'm not calling for a boycott i
don't want them canceled i don't want
you to
you know break the windows of their
stores or anything like that
but i didn't find their hummus to be
that creamy
i found the falafels to be not as
crunchy as i would like and i'm not
going to be going to cava
cava whatever you want to call it
anymore i'm just not going to be doing
it
not going to be doing it people uh all
right
i think that's enough for one day i
actually have to head to the doctor
because
i am 44 years old and one of the things
that will happen to you
as a wise man i'll tell i'll tell one
story quick we got a little time here
uh so i used to work at uh electronics
boutique many of you
uh know that i wrote a little bit about
in my book i was i was assistant manager
of electronics boutique in broadway mall
hicksville
long island in the in the late 90s as i
was doing stand-up in new york city at
night and i would sell video games
during the day it was a real superhero
kind of story
and it was my first job out of college
in 99 i moved more pokemon red than
anybody for color game boy i mean
you know if you buying a a red pokemon
you had to go through me
okay uh anyway one day i was i was at
electronics
which by the way electronics boutique
was eventually bought by gamestop so for
those of you that are younger you know
gamestop you don't know electronics
boutique but i hope
a few of you remember electronics
boutique um
so it was it you know electronics was
eventually bought by gamestop anyway i'm
working on electronics boutique i'm the
assistant manager
and one night late night we're like
putting up you know when you go into
video game series they've got like
cardboard cutouts
there's sonic the hedgehog and mario and
everybody else and
whatever the other games are now i don't
even know um but there was a guy who
worked there i was a system manager
there was a guy who's like a part-time
video game salesman you're getting paid
like eight bucks an hour
and he was probably in his like early
50s something like that
and like you know he's kind of
overweight and he was a mess and his
hair was a mess and he was
greasy and he just looked miserable and
i think he had been out of jail actually
he was a drug
former drug addict and everything else
but he was really trying to get his life
together and i actually really liked the
guy
and we were putting up the things late
night and
he's climbing up the ladder and i'm
holding the ladder and he's putting
something i think it was
sonic i'm pretty sure it was sonic like
a big like cardboard cutout of sonic he
has to get it like
on the window there and i hand him sonic
and i'm holding the ladder
and as i hand him sonic i hand him sound
like i hear a tear
some kind of tear and he starts
screaming writhing writhing in pain
and he ripped something in his shoulder
as he was trying to hang sonic
you know somewhere in the in the front
display of the store
and he looked down at me and he almost
had tears in his eyes and he was in pain
and this is a you know again he had
been through jail and drug addict he was
really trying to get his life together
he looked at me
and now i'm young i'm 20 21 something
like that he looks at me he goes dave
your body will betray you
one day your body will betray you
okay and uh that always stuck with me
because it seemed very sad like here was
this man and all he was trying to do was
put sonic on a wall and he
did something horrible to his shoulder i
don't even know if i saw him again after
that i think he had surgery and
disappeared
why do i mention all of this i have a
good reason yesterday
i was shooting hoops with david and my
brother-in-law
we were playing horse and i was feeling
a little cocky because i was shooting
really well and i decided to do like
some
crazy ass spin move and
as some of you may know i blew out my
acl in my knee and my left knee
a couple years ago and i tried to do
this stupid move yesterday
and as i did it i just the knee just
completely
buckled again there's no acl there i
don't even have an acl the acl you know
if you have a torn acl
you can run straight but you can't run
this way that's why so many basketball
players because of cutting
and spinning and everything that's why
they blow out their acls anyway
so i'm going to the doctor today because
i'm limping around here and i'm swollen
and everything else so i'm a 44 year old
guy
with a torn acl but i guess i picked the
right career right because i wanted to
be in the nba
but here i am where i can just sit at a
desk that anyway uh
oh i'm getting a correction i like that
when we fact check on the fly
kava kava did not lessen whites by 37
percent
they lessened it from 30 so just to be
very clear here
they were 37 white they did get it down
to 21
so they lessened it by 16 which it's
like cava are you even trying come on
can we fire more white people because
the 37 when i thought it they went down
30 percent
percent on white people it was like wow
you guys are doing it right social
justice man
but you're only going down 16 seems kind
of weak to me it's like
let's get a couple white people fired
okay uh all right guys
my first interview of the year is with
former congresswoman and the last same
democrat on planet earth tulsi gabbard
uh we're gonna be putting that up later
this week and tulsi will be
i believe making a surprise announcement
or two that you might want to hear
i don't want to lead too much but i
think some good things may be coming and
she really i mean i've said it before
but it's like
man if there was any chance that any
liberty minded somewhat
centrist person could still remain a
democrat that would have been through
tulsi
the anti-war thing moderate positions on
on abortion
and a whole series of other issues that
i've talked to her about before which if
you haven't seen you can check out
my original interview with tulsi it was
like she was the choice that the
democrats could have made if they wanted
to remain
a sort of centrist sensible party and
she
demolished such a beautiful video
absolutely demolished
kamala during the debates and then
kamala dropped out she was polling at
zero and then what did they decide to do
they decided to make her vp which
ultimately of course
will be president because biden ain't
sticking around for that long although
again i'm not even totally sure that
that's going to happen at all
the other thing that's up right now guys
you can check out my speech from turning
point usa which
we taped well it was live in florida
right before
christmas and a bunch of other stuff so
i'm gonna go to the doctor
hope you all have a great day and uh we
will see what happens with georgia i'll
be on laura ingraham tonight
and then we'll be recapping everything
tomorrow all right see ya